[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
كيدي هذا النجار علي بابا دوما يتجول في
الغابه يجمع اخشاب كي يصنع نافذه منها او
بابا هذا النجار علي بابا دوما يتجول في
بابا يوما في الغابه يتمشى لمح لصوصا قرب
مغاره فا اختبا وجلس يراقبهم شاهد ما
فعلوا فاحتار قالوا افتح يا سمسم بقي علي
بابا مذهول ابتعدت عن بابها صخره وسيدهم
يامر بدخول لبثوا قليلا بعدها خرجوا
وقالوا اغلق يا سمسم ثم انصرفوا وعلي بابا
بدخولها اصبح مهتم علي بابا
لالالالالا علي بابا
لالالالا علي بابا لالال
لاالا كرر ما فع علي بابا دخل وفيها وجد
العجب ذهبا وكنوزا اموال عبا كيسه ثم
انسحب عاد لزوجته مسرورا قال سنعطي
للفقراء وللناس نعيد امانتهم ونصير جميعا
سعداء رجع الاشرار الى الكهف ولم يجدوا جل
الاموال وهنالك قد فهموا الدرس لن يفلح
ابدا محتج علي بابا
لالالالالا علي بابا
لالالالا علي بابا
[موسيقى]
لالالالالا